it's one of those games that turn grand
masters into little kids when they see
the move sam you must have been really
happy when you dropped the bomb of queen
takes e5 or not yeah i mean i felt kind
of bad about it hagar has been a hero to
me for a very long time you know back
when i was growing up where did you
treat a hero he's only four years older
but i started chest late so when i was
1200 he was already basically a
grandmaster and he's you know top young
american at the time and yeah i somehow
felt a little guilty about this one but
only a little bit queen takes e5 was
pretty satisfying to play amazing move
indeed mating you don't even need we
were pointing out uh if if you take here
you don't even need the the rook
it's a very it's amazing it's not every
day you see a mate like this yeah no it
was i was very happy with that yeah for
sure it was felt great great start by
the way 2-0 difficult last round game
but still two and one if you said ah you
come into the day and you end up with
two and one one win two draws two wins
are lost you'd say yeah i'm not not a
bad dear the officer yeah i'm totally
satisfied with today i mean part of
fischer random there's all these wild
positions from the start is every now
and then you're just gonna do one dumb
thing and get clobbered and that's what
happened i missed knight c5 against
maxime next thing i know my bishop is on
h1 and i'm basically laying down a piece
it's actually funny if you pull up the
final position against him where i
resigned this is how you know you're
playing fischer random is uh he played
knight takes a seven and i was i was
just so shocked that he blundered so bad
yeah the last one just the last move the
game literally the last move of the game
i was shocked that i was just shocked
that he had blundered so badly with
knight takes h7 i was about to go play
rook h1 takes a1
so it was all just it's all just i don't
know i mean i certainly don't take
losses nearly as hard when it's just
sort of
somewhat fun exhibition games that
aren't rated and don't really count for
much but it's been a lot of fun uh
already i mean i i certainly am much
happier making if i'm gonna make two
points out of three i'm certainly much
happier making two wins and a loss than
than one than i went into draws but yeah
it's been great so far
the experience now playing today we were
enthralled i mean there was great moves
being played everywhere do you feel
there should be more official random
events well i'm sort of of two minds
about it because in general for the
excitement of chess yes i absolutely
believe so uh i think that would sort of
screw me over a bit just because i think
that
both in terms of the shuffling of the
pieces making opening theory and
previous knowledge essentially useless
and the rapid time control that i think
in classical chess there's a very
healthy balance between uh talent and
hard work and where how far each one
will get you and as soon as you start
shuffling the pieces to get rid of
opening preparation and who's worked
harder at that and then you start making
it faster so that calculation doesn't
matter as much uh just the more talented
people get a huge advantage compared to
the harder working types we all know
which category i sort of qualify myself
in but uh well maybe i have to adjust
that after a nice day today but yeah so
in general uh i would definitely like to
see more of these events but let's put
it this way i would like to see more of
these events without ex getting rid of
classical events i think as long as no
classical events are harmed by it and
removed but no it's a lot of fun for
sure and uh while it might not be as
serious it's definitely more fun all
right well you may not consider yourself
that talented we definitely think you
are and thank you so much for
enthralling us not with this game the
the other one good luck in the rest of
the game well i mean even for for uh for
a great game like this you do need one
like helpful losing participant and i
provided that this time uh you know
before you go i'm just gonna i'm gonna
make sure i'm gonna make sure that board
is up that one right there yeah all
right i'm gonna do that the funny thing
is actually last thing i'll say is i do
just think i'm just worse if he took my
knight instead of knight takes e5 but
nobody cares queen takes e5
this was money this was money thanks so
much we'll see you guys tomorrow yes
absolutely sam shankland with
a tough loss there on the last round but
a great day for him starting with two
out of two finishing with two out of
three let's take a look